tenemos una función llamada f aunque no
tenemos que llamarla así es la letra más
comúnmente usada para las funciones y si
le doy una entrada una entrada válida y
uso la variable x para esta entrada
válida la función va a mapear esta
entrada o producir una salida que
llamaremos fx ya hemos hablado de la
noción de dominio el dominio es el
conjunto de todos los valores de entrada
en los que la función está definida este
es el dominio toma un valor de aquí lo
uso en mi x y entonces la función me va
a dar una f x si tomamos algo que está
fuera del dominio que voy a poner en
otro color y tratamos de usarlo como
entrada de esta función nuestra función
no dirá oye yo no estoy definida para
este valor que está fuera del dominio
así que no me va a entregar nada otra
cosa interesante para pensar y de hecho
es el propósito de este vídeo es que
conocemos las entradas válidas que son
el dominio
que hay de todas las salidas que puede
producir la función pues tenemos un
hombre para esto les llamamos el rango
de la función hay un par de definiciones
para el rango de una función la
definición más típica es el conjunto de
todos los valores de salida posibles así
que entré a algo en el dominio la
función nos va a generar un valor y por
definición como ésta es una salida de
nuestra función pues estará en el rango
ya que aquí están todas las salidas
posibles de la función y éstas formarán
el rango así que esto es el conjunto
de todos los valores
de salida
posibles
que una función puede tomar digamos que
tengo una entrada x en una función f y
nos dará una f x y digamos que la
definición de la función lo que nos dice
que dada una x cual f x resultará pues
la definición nos dice fx es igual a lo
que sea mi entrada al cuadrado x al
cuadrado este es un repaso sabemos que
el dominio es el conjunto de todas las
entradas válidas aquí cuáles son las
entradas válidas puedo tomar cualquier
número real ponerlo como entrará aquí
elevarlo al cuadrado sin problemas así
que aquí el dominio son todos los
números reales
pero cuál será el rango cuál es el
conjunto de todas las salidas posibles
bueno para ayudarnos a pensar en ello
voy a dibujar una gráfica de cómo se
vería esto la gráfica de fx igual a
equis cuadrada va a verse más o menos
así va a ser una parábola con el vértice
justo en el origen
esta es la gráfica de igual a fx aquí
están los ejes x y xi cuál es el
conjunto de todas las salidas posibles
en este caso es el conjunto de todas las
10 posibles y vemos que ya puede tomar
todos los valores no negativos y puede
ser 0 puede ser uno puede ser pi puede
ser
pero ya nunca puede ser negativo por lo
que podemos expresar el rango de dos
formas uno
nuestra llave fx es un miembro o
pertenece a los números reales tales que
fx sea mayor o igual que cero podemos
escribirlo de esta manera o podemos usar
una anotación no tan formal
podemos decir que fx es mayor o igual a
cero fx no será negativa el conjunto de
todos los números no negativos será
nuestro rango hagamos otro ejemplo para
que esto nos quede más claro digamos que
tengo ag x que es igual a x cuadrada
entre x podemos tratar de simplificar gx
y decir bueno tengo x cuadrada entre x
esto es lo mismo que decir que de x es
igual a x pero hay que tener cuidado
porque aquí tenemos una x en nuestro
denominador en nuestro dominio x no
puede ser igual a 0 si x es igual a 0
vamos a tener 0 entre 0 que es una
indeterminación así que para que nuestra
función sea idéntica a nuestra
definición tenemos que decir que x
no debe ser igual a cero gm x es igual a
x siempre que x sea diferente de cero
ahora estas dos definiciones de
funciones son equivalentes incluso
podemos graficar las
una línea con pendiente 1 pero que
tendrá un hueco en 0 y continuará el
dominio aquí es x pertenece a los
números reales tal que x no sea igual a
0 y el rango va a ser lo mismo el rango
es f x que pertenece a los números
reales tal que fx sea diferente de ser
entonces el dominio x pertenece a los
números reales tal que x no sea igual a
0 y el rango f x pertenece a los números
reales tal que fx sea diferente de 0
aquí lo importante es comprender que el
rango es el conjunto de todos los
valores de salida posibles de nuestra
función
el dominio son todos los posibles
valores de entrada de la función